pra que serve mudar o mundo
para tentar responder essa pergunta eu
queria compartilhar um pouco com vocês a
minha história que eu tenho aprendido
nessa caminhada que começou há 28 anos
atrás quando eu nasci e as primeiras
lembranças que eu tenho da minha
infância são com quatro ou cinco anos de
idade o que aconteceu nos primeiros anos
eu não faço a menor idéia
mas o que sempre me contaram é que eu
era uma criança linda amorosa calma e
alegre
e assim eu fui levando comigo esse
personagem durante muitos anos
só que esse personagem tinha um defeito
ele tinha que ser perfeita e assim foi
desconstruindo na minha infância
adolescência assim como a maior parte
dos jovens não foi ensinado a reconhecer
que mesmo com pouca idade eu já tinha
muita história
é como se o passado eo presente de um
jovem não valessem pra nada
afinal o que importa é sempre o futuro
desde o momento da nossa primeira as
frustrações quando nossos pais nos dizem
meu filho isso não é importante
vai ver quando ficarem adulto aí sim
será complicado e esse ficar adulto às
vezes demora bastante tempo
quando crescemos a vida nos dá a
oportunidade de pegarmos o timão do
nosso barco e navegar mos para onde
quisermos ou simplesmente deixar muu o
marlos levar talvez uma primeira
oportunidade da direção é o meu barco
tem acontecido logo quando terminei o
colégio pode ser ruim ter que escolher a
profissão com 17 anos eu acho que
deveria ser diferente
mas independente da opção mais
importante é ter que fazer uma escolha
e nesse momento nos damos conta que não
temos a menor idéia do caminho a seguir
porque de fato não conhecemos quem é que
está pilotando o nosso barco e lá fui eu
fazer minha primeira escolha
profissional
não tinha a menor idéia do que quer
fazer e acabei escolhendo fazer
administração
achei que os problemas estão resolvidos
e as pessoas ficavam perguntando mas
felipe porque a administração obviamente
que não tinha uma resposta e naquele
momento eu tive encontrar uma resposta
que fizesse sentido pra mim e eu
encontrei uma e eu respondi para aquelas
pessoas que me perguntava eu vou fazer
administração porque eu quero ganhar
muito dinheiro e assim eu comecei a
carreira profissional sem ter a menor
idéia do que estava fazendo
comecei trabalhando na empresa do meu
pai até cansar de levar comigo a
bandeira de ser o filho do dono
depois foi trabalhar numa outra
organização trabalhava de terno e
gravata com uma base pastinha embaixo do
braço
no escritório que tinha vista da cidade
inteira estava super poderoso super
importante
meus pais achavam que eu estava com a
vida feita já
até que um dia esse caminho parou de
fazer sentido para mim e eu me dei conta
que aquela motivação que eu tinha
entrado na faculdade não era minha
quando eu percebi isso eu mudei meu
barco exatamente na direção oposta e fui
trabalhar no terceiro setor como
voluntário de algumas organizações
sociais
me sentia bem sabendo que eu não estava
trabalhando pelo dinheiro
me sentia feliz em saber que eu estava
trabalhando por um bem maior e não pelo
dinheiro
nessa época eu trabalhava para ajudar as
pessoas a terem mais oportunidades
usava os meus conhecimentos de gestão de
marketing para apoiar o ngc que precisa
precisavam de ajuda
eu queria mudar o mundo eu realmente
acreditava que eu estava conseguindo
e eu me dei conta que quando eu tinha
entrado na faculdade eu queria muito
ganhar muito dinheiro e eu tinha saído
sem ganhar um centavo ou seja exatamente
o oposto
eu passei mais ou menos quatro anos da
minha vida achando que eu tinha vindo
pra terra com a missão de mudar um eu
achei que tinha encontrado o meu dom uma
vocação mas não era nada disso
eu simplesmente
tava tentando encontrar um sentido para
a minha vida e coloquei no trabalho
toda expectativa nessa época me joguei
no universo das pessoas que trabalham
para fazer o bem e achei que assim eu ia
resolver todos os meus problemas e que
tinha encontrado um caminho para a minha
felicidade
isso me levou a morar em são paulo a
fazer uma série de escolhas e decisões
que só foram deixando mais confusos
eu me dei conta que essa minha busca era
um pouco egoísta porque no fundo eu
simplesmente tava querendo construir
algo grandioso e era só isso que eu
reconheci que os grandes líderes quando
começaram não queriam fazer nada de
grandioso simplesmente acreditavam em
algo e foram atrás sem se preocupar com
as respostas
hoje em dia eu converso com muitos
jovens e essa vontade de querer mudar o
mundo é algo recorrente
eu fico me perguntando mas o que está
por trás desse desejo
será que o mundo está tão ruim assim ou
será que simplesmente estamos querendo
encontrar um sentido para nossas vidas
ninguém nunca soube explicar o que
acontece depois que a gente morre ou
sequer sabe dizer o que a gente faz veio
fazer aqui na terra mas vir ao mundo com
a missão para salvá lo
parece uma grande missão e obviamente
tem atraído muita gente
além de mudar o mundo queremos trabalhar
de forma colaborativa queremos
empreender
não queremos ter chefes o horário para
cumprir
queremos encontrar um trabalho que nos
preenche que realmente faça sentido para
nossas vidas mas eu acho que essa busca
não está no trabalho ideal ou na vontade
de querer colaborar ou de empreender ou
em qualquer outra coisa externa
as respostas que a gente busca não estão
nesses grandes jargões eu acho que cada
um traz simplesmente querendo encontrar
os
o espaço no mundo e para fazer isso se
conhecer melhor
é fundamental para que a busca seja
autêntica
às vezes esse caminho é solitário não é
colaborativo
às vezes esse caminho é doloroso e não é
divertido
muitas vezes esse caminho não é cool
sexo e talvez por isso que fazer terapia
ainda é coisa de louco
agora aceitar que as respostas não estão
um empreendedorismo na colaboração ou em
qualquer outra coisa externa pode não
ser fácil mas faz toda a diferença e foi
um pouco disso que aconteceu comigo isso
de querer mudar o mundo me ajudou a
poderem compreender melhor olhar pra
dentro e ver de onde vinha tudo aquilo
ou melhor o que estava por trás de tudo
aquilo que possibilitou que eu fizesse
as minhas próprias escolhas e se elas
estavam certas ou erradas
o tempo fui me dizendo esses
questionamentos me ajudaram a quebrar
aquele felipe perfeito e esses
questionamentos me proporcionaram fazer
uma viagem a viagem para conhecer de
verdade quem era o felipe
nessa viagem apesar de termos vários
aprendizados ser uma viagem incrível
às vezes a viagem pode ser dura dói
reconhecer que aquele felipe perfeito
que eu achei que existia não passava de
uma grande ilusão e pra mim o mais
importante nessa história foi saber
respeitar o meu tempo e aceitar que não
ter respostas faz parte do processo e
que pra ir mais a fundo é preciso pedir
ajuda
eu demorei pra reconhecer que quanto
mais vulnerável me tornava mais forte eu
ficava eu faço análise há alguns anos e
é uma das formas que eu encontrei para
me dar esse espaço
mas eu acredito que esses espaços não
deveriam só existir dentro de consultor
eu acho que sim esses passos deveriam
existir nas coisas onde estamos
diariamente como escola universidade
entre tantos outros e isso trouxe uma
motivação para no ano passado
começar uma iniciativa junto com dois
amigos para criar esse espaço para as
pessoas pra mim representa a escola ou
universidade que eu gostaria de ter tido
uma escola de empreendedorismo através
do autoconhecimento
só que pirata pirata porque o que
acontece lá nada tem a ver com o formato
de uma escola onde os professores ensino
e os alunos aprendem é um espaço para as
pessoas se conectarem com seus sonhos
com suas vontades e a partir daí
desenvolverem seus projetos com mais
autonomia
nesse processo os sentir vem antes do
fazer do querer
mas depois que faz sentido a maneira de
aprender a fazendo literalmente
colocando a mão na massa
a partir desses pequenos projectos que
são realizados
as pessoas percebem que são livres para
experimentar o que quiserem
e é assim que se dá todo aprendizado
através da experiência de cada um mas eu
acho que é muito mais valioso genuíno
ouvir isso nas pessoas que já
participaram desse processo do que ouvir
isso de mim que obviamente sou
apaixonado pela iniciativa
então pra isso eu queria mostrar pra
vocês um pequeno vídeo
foi uma chave que vai ser livre para
fazer o que quiser não tem um programa
coisa que você vai construir com as
pessoas
ontem eu não sabia o que ia fazer aqui
eu não sabia o que era o lasu mas eu
tinha certeza que o fim foi a parte da
história foi o espaço de descoberta de
tempo nem teoriza que poderia ser gente
fizesse disse que sozinho não chega lá
de dentro que me ajudou a ter uma cabeça
mais aberta fica mais sensibilidade pra
mim o que eu gosto de ter um trabalho
mais conectado com o que eu realmente
acredito que possa entregar valor e que
passa me sustentar também gente não
precisa seguir o caminho dos outros
o conjunto de tudo isso não carinho
atenção e drogas conseguiu terminar
atrás quando você é geninho deve
simplesmente à caminho
[Música]
nesse processo o que menos importa são
os projectos que as pessoas realizam se
depois de lá vão ser artistas
empreendedores músicos ou se vão
trabalhar na empresa do pai ou uma
empresa tradicional
pouco importa o que importa é que saem
de lá com confiança e coragem pra
fazerem suas próprias escolhas seja lá
quais forem
antes de olhar pra fora
precisamos olhar para dentro ouvir isso
da marina silva algumas semanas atrás
e pra mim fez todo o sentido ela dizia
que assim como nossos antepassados
gregos que queriam ser sábios livres
os romanos que queriam ser fortes
precisamos resgatar esse aprendizado de
ser é muito mais importante do que ter
ou fazer esse não dá para mudar o mundo
a única possibilidade é mudarmos a nós
mesmos e isso sim é a maior contribuição
que cada um de nós pode deixar pra
humanidade
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]